amber heard fires her pr team and hires
a new one
amid the ongoing defamation trial
between amber and her ex-husband johnny
depp she finds herself making some
professional changes e.t can confirm the
aquaman star has fired her previous pr
reps and hired someone new to shed light
on the situation a crisis manager is
opening up to et speculating as to why
amber made the switch
for the last several weeks depp's team
has presented witnesses to challenge
herds mental health as well as audio
tapes of her saying she hit him so
there's no way the media wouldn't give
her some bad headlines with the defense
getting ready to present its side of the
story it feels like an extremely
impulsive and unforced error to switch
media teams at a moment when they should
be going on offense the trial kicked off
on april 11th depp is suing her for
defamation related to her 2018 op-ed
published in the washington post where
she alleges she was the victim of
domestic violence you only sued the
author
of this article amber heard correct
which seems she was the one making the
statements yes i
had the opportunity to
fight back
not only has depp himself testified but
also several witnesses who worked
closely with the former couple and the
allegations are shocking and did you
have any discussions with ms hurd on the
way to coachella that evening
we had a conversation pertaining to the
surprise she left in the boss's bed
prior to leaving the apartment and when
you refer to the surprise in the boss's
bed what are you referring to
the defecation
and what did miss heard say about the
defecation in mr duff's bed
a horrible practical jerk gone wrong
when we initially
had contact with amber heard in 2016
she indicated her desire to pay 3.5
million dollars to the aclu
so it's fair to say that she has not
donated 3.5 million dollars as of today
to the aclu true that's right depp has
completed his testimony and hurt is
expected to take the stand this week
[Music]